bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
pour cette nouvelle session des
webinaires la 11e et aujourd'hui nous
avons apportées l'analyse factorielle
des correspondances et plus précisément
l'analyse des correspondances multiples
j'espère que vous allez bien
donc comme toujours un jeu pour rappel
la session du jour elle se base sur un
des chapitres du site analyseur sur
lequel vous trouverez les différentes
commandes et tous les éléments pour
aller éventuellement un peu plus loin
alors que ma chaque fois écouté
basculons sur sur hertz tu diot et on va
prendre l'habitude comme pour toutes les
séances veut faire un nouveau projet ce
qui permet d'avoir le code un petit peu
orangé donc on veut faire new project il
tombe toujours vous avez vu quand je
suis en stream bien du coup ou mon pc un
petit peu au ralenti ce que je vais la
fenêtre ouverture pour faire un nouveau
gros jamais je suis allé trop vite donc
nous directory new project nous binaire
11 et on va laisser les studios avancé
alors l'analyse factorielle les
correspondances 1 il existe sous there
on a un peu trois familles de fonction
pour ce type d' analyse là je reviendrai
juste après sur le principe de l'analyse
factorielle mais vous avez quelques
fonctions sur l'analyse des
correspondances qui sont présentes de
base dans l'air et puis il ya deux
pattes kitsch en particulier qui sont
dédiées à l'analyse des correspondances
vous avez le package adieu 4 et vous
avez le package facto minder aujourd'hui
on va voir plus en détail le package
adeo 4 après pourquoi de 4 facto myners
pour ma part j'ai une petite préférence
pour la délicate parce qu'il permet
d'être plus est à paris tap la factory
nerfs et à côté un peu tout en un après
7,2 c'est un peu une question de
préférence
sachez que vous retrouverez sur le
chapitre analyser à béziers le code pour
les deux package
alors peut-être pour commencer la
session applique le principe de
l'analyse factorielle le principe de
l'analyse factorielle consiste à essayer
de résumer l'information quand on a un
grand nombre de variables
on peut considérer du coup que nos
individus peuvent être projeté dans un
espace à plusieurs dimensions
or et un axe pour chacune de nos
variable si vous avez une quinzaine de
variables ça voudrait dire mettre des
individus dans un espace à 15 dimensions
et est-ce qu'on aimerait voir c'est ce
qui aurait moyen de trouver une autre
manière de représenter nos individus qui
résumerait un maximum de la formation
alors je vais vous proposer une première
illustration avec un cac à deux
variables et je vais d'ailleurs commencé
par deux variables quantitative dont
juste pour vous illustrer les choses
supposons qu'on prenne le fichier lice
alors le fichier vis à un fichier un
exemple que l'on a toujours dans l'air
dans lequel vous avez notamment vous
avez 150 mesures qui viennent de fleurs
d'iris et vous avez notamment une
variable qui vous indiquent que la
longueur d'une pétales et la largeur
d'une pétales est ce qu'on va faire je
vais on va représenter cette information
là sur un graphique
donc on va toucher d'abord chargé le
tailles diverses
je vais monter dans un graphique en
scrutant
donc si je reviens ici session 11 sur
l'analyse factorielle
et on a commencé dupoux pas un exemple
introductif donc on va charger de
tailles diverses
je leur mette un rôle clé pour qu'ils
puissent se réaliser par lui même et
donc et d'avoir présenté je ferme ma
fille qui veut partir de myrys jugé paul
vi et je représentais en x la largeur
des pétales vous rappelle angélique
l'outil glisse le jeune de nuit à es et
je vais indiquer en x que je veux
représenter métal 9 et en y et al points
et on va faire un graphique de points je
rebrousse poil indiqué types de
graphiques voulu si je réalise ce
graphique donc là vous voyez les
différentes mesures vous avez chaque
point représente une fleur données et
vous avez du coup on voit qu'une forte
corrélation entre la longueur d'un
pétale et la largeur d'un pétale quand
on est sur deux variables et bien chaque
observation ici chaque point est
représentée ici dans un espace à deux
dimensions avec une coordonnée en x inc
or de niang y
l'accord donné en x et dans la longueur
du méthane l'accord donné à y étendre la
largeur du pétale la question qui peut
se poser c'est est il possible de faire
2 2
de skis jamais il est possible de
changer le système de coordonnées
d'accord de trouver de nouveaux axes qui
permettrait de représenter mieux de
donner d'accord quand on est dans un
insiste donc quand on réfléchit en
termes de coordonnées spatiales encore
nos deux variables représentent deux
axes de coordonnées et est-ce qu'on peut
changer le système de coordonnées pour
représenter un petit peu différemment
non variable et c'est ça finalement le
principe une analyse factorielle qui est
trouvé un nouveau système de coordonnées
pour représenter nous donne est un peu
différente
alors ce qu'il faut en retenir c'est
qu'on a plusieurs types d'analysés
factorielles si on réalise une analyse
factorielle à partir de variables
quantitative
on réalise une analyse en proposant
principal si jamais variable qualitative
on parle d' analyse factorielle des
correspondances lorsqu il y a plusieurs
variables qualitative on parle à ce
moment là d'une assez m analyse des
correspondances multiples et enfin on
peut avoir des méthodes d'analysé mixte
lorsqu'on va combiner variable
quantitative et qualitative
je reviendrai sur les différentes
fonctions qui sont impliqués là ce stade
là je veux juste vous faire un petit
exemple introductif et donc du coup on
va réaliser une analyse des
correspondances en analysant
correspondance principal puisqu'on est
sur des variables ici mellick pourrait
faire une à cp qui en anglais se dit
principales composantes analysis bca et
avec le package à 10h04 on va charger
ça se fait tout simplement avec la
fonction du 10 points et celle à
laquelle on va passer notre fléchi de
données avec uniquement des variables
qui nous intéresse donc pour là ça va
être assez singer partir du coup deux
hélices je vais sélectionner et bien
deux variables qui commence par le mot
pétales dont star prive étals on va me
faire juste pour vous rappeler sa main
même si je fais ça avec un selleck start
with j'ai plus un tableau avec deux
colonnes et tout ça je vais le passer à
la fonction du 10 points et c'est un élu
et stocker tout ça dans un objet que
généreuse pour résultat alors on nous
demande tout d'abord un nombre dax pour
pas que ça revienne un par la suite je
me dis simplement un effet 4 2 on y
reviendra sur le nombre d'actes je veux
faire l'analyse sur deux axes je vais
faire c'est le message qui m'est donnée
en si je fais ceci j'ai plus de
questions interactive qui me demande
combien je vais garder taxe demande
analyse la g2 variable donc je veux
prendre mes deux axes et je vais avoir
mon objet on viendra invite à l'heure
sur le détail des différentes fonctions
mais si on veut explorer rapidement les
résultats de l'analyse factorielle de
manière interactive on peut le faire
avec un paquet qui s'appelle explore et
explore à une fonction expérience à
laquelle on peut passer un résultat
d'analysés factorielles donc là je vais
simplement appelée explore exploit 2.2.2
leur rêve pour vous montrer les
résultats de l'analyse factorielle il
s'agit si à ce stade de comprendre la
logique
analyse on viendra sur toutes les
fonctions juste après ce qu'il faut
retenir c'est que ce qu'on a fait vous
vous souvenez
je vous remontre le premier graphique
que nous avions qui est à la
présentation de mes individus dans un
espace à deux dimensions d'accord en xp
ta life et en y est alors yves ce que
fait l'analyse factorielle s'est trouvé
un nouveau système de coordonnées
on va voir représenter un nom ici dans
un nouveau système de coordonnées on a
toujours deux axes puisqu'on est dans un
espace à deux dimensions
sauf qu'on a trouvé un premier axe qui
va maximiser l'explication de la
variance est ici vous voyez dans ce
nouvel espace à la dimension où j'ai
représenté mais points mais pour j'ai un
premier acte qui va concentrer 98% de la
variante ils ont du coup 90% des
variations vont se situer sur le premier
axe est le deuxième axe va me concentrer
seulement 1,86 pour cent de cette
version cela si on revient sur premier
graphique intuitivement ce que vous
voyez c'est qu'on a un premier axe qui
est le long la droite de régression ici
et un deuxième acte est la
perpendiculaire par rapport à la droite
de régression
j'ai juste représenter mon nuage de
points mais dans un nouveau système de
coordonnées d'accord et dans ce système
de coordonnées et bien du coup j'ai
trouvé des coordonnées ou le maximum de
la variation des variations
l'échantillon se retrouve selon premier
axe est très peu de variation sur le
deuxième acte est donc si jamais je
voulais résumé l'information contenue
grosso modo nous avons des pétales qui
sont grandes en grande largeur et une
grande longueur et des pétales qui sont
petits et je pourrais me contenter de
uniquement la valeur du premier axe
parce qu'elle résume l'essentiel de
l'information
le deuxième axe n'apporte que peu
d'informations additionnelles
et donc du coup en faisant mon analyse
factorielle je trouve à nouveau système
de coordonnées
maintenant que j'arrive au sam de
coordonnées ou la plus grande la
majorité de la formation et contenu
uniquement par mon premier axe les
coordonnées des points sur premières acc
serait suffisant pour résumer à
l'information et donc du coup on voit
que l'analyse factorielle ce sont des
approches qui permettent de réduire le
nombre de variables
c'était vraiment un exemple rapide
illustratif on viendrait un tout à
l'heure sur sur explorèrent mais
explorèrent en fait c'est un une
interface graphique pour explorer les
différents éléments et si jamais on veut
garder le code de la partie interactive
je peux cliquer en bas à gauche sur le
bouton obtenir le code r ça me donne un
code pin qui s'attire aussi mauvaise
qu'on va changer tout ça que je peux
récupérer j'ai fait un papier je ferme
mon interface je vais récupérer sa donc
là en fait je vais faire un jeu peut
utiliser la fonction pré pare brise on
explore qui va transformer mais les
résultats un peu sous un autre format
et puis ensuite avoir recours à la
fonction pca en pelote l'or qui me
permet simplement de reproduire le
graphique que nous avons vus on va
enregistrer tout ça donc là c'est street
session du binaire 11
donc là ce qu'on a vu c'était vraiment
un exemple simple avec uniquement un
espace à deux dimensions que ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on arrive à se
représenter et on va voir maintenant le
cas de figure du général mais c'est
toujours le même principe c'est que on
peut considérer que lorsqu'on a rebondi
variable qui décrivent nos observations
et bien nos observations peuvent être du
coût représenté dans un espace à
dimension où la valeur prise par chaque
variable représente 27 un axe de cet
espace à dimension et on va essayer les
finalistes factorielle de changer le
système de coordonnées et d'essayer de
trouver des axes dans ce nouveau système
de coordonnées qui vont représenter le
maximum de la variance et qui vont du
coup permettre de résumer l'information
contenue dans nos données
on va revenir à un exemple plus complet
et cette fois ci nous allons utiliser le
jeu de données
hdv 2003 on commence à bien connaître
donc on va charger relationnel est
chargé le jeu de mots hdv 2003
cette fois ci nous allons utiliser que
des variables catégorielles donc comme
vous les dix ans quand on utilise des
variables qui sont continue on va avoir
recours à une ac p analyse des
correspondances principal lorsqu'on a
recours à des vagues catégorielles on
doit vous fera du coup une analyse
placement ce multiple et puis si on
avait un mélange des deux on pourrait
faire une analyse mixte pour savoir
quelles sont les fonctions qu'on
n'utilisera je vous renvoie du coup
analyseur et je vous montre rapidement
sur un analyseur le chapitre analyse
factorielle
au début on vous présente les différents
types donc lorsqu'on a des mariages
quantitative
c'est une ac b et avec kad et o cap
quand il aura la fonction du diplôme
psc1
lorsqu'on à plusieurs variables
qualitative menacé m
on aura au cours la fonction du dit
assez m
et si on veut avoir un mélange de
manière continue et catégorielles vous
pouvez essayer d'avoir recours à
l'analyse mixte avec la fonction du 10.6
donc il suffit juste de savoir le type
de fonction tease et tout le reste en
fait se fera de manière similaire
si jamais vous voulez teese est plutôt
facto manière sachez que les fonctions
correspondantes sont les fonctions et
c'est la mca et f à et menait alors nous
avons maintenant notre que je donnais
hdv 2003 ce qu'on va faire c'est
rapidement un tout petit peu de recul
d'âge donc pour gagner en temps je vais
copier le code qui est ici je vais
revenir dans le jeu de données
je vais la recopier donc on va partir de
hdv 2003 et on va faire une variable
groupe d'âge d'accord donc avec la
fonction caps pour si on s'en souvient
pas on peut trouver cult via le had been
et chercher les alignent deux
questionnaires
vous avez le numérique price dividing
donc la cote de hdmi 2003 à 16 25 45 93
bright falls include the way through ça
me permet en fait de créer une variable
groupes d'âge
je vous montre le résultat avec un fret
hdv 2003 groupe a donc on est parti
d'une variable âge qu'on la reconnaît du
coup
une variable groupes d'âge et puis on va
faire une nouvelle variable avec notre
niveau d'études
donc je vais copier la variable hdv de
la variable étude la variable yves
études je vais la copier dents longues
études
et puis on va changer les niveaux de la
variable études en prime est imprimé à
primaire secondaire et secondaire
technique professionnelle pour arriver à
faire des regroupements et je vous
montre le résultat ça nous permet de
regrouper des éléments ensemble ça des
choses qu'on avait déjà vue dans les
sessions précédentes et ont besoin pour
regrouper des variables ensemble ça peut
se faire avec l'hiver brille coline
alors ce que vaut ce que l'on souhaite
faire maintenant d'accord c'est une
analyse des correspondances multiples et
on inclut un certain nombre de variables
l'idée c'est que quand on fait une
analyse factorielle on met ensemble des
variables qui relève d'un même ordre et
que l'on souhaite
synthétisée ensemble et là par exemple
pour notre acl donc je vais faire un
objet assez m d'accord le résultat notre
analyse des correspondances je vais
partir du coude hdv 2003 je vais
sélectionner les variables que je vais
inclure dans mon analyse donc ici pour
l'exemple aujourd'hui on va prendre
avaria groupes d'âge la variable sexe la
variable étude assez vague pour créer et
puis on va regarder également le fait de
pratiquer la pêche ou la chasse
le fait d'aller au cinéma depuis zine et
de bricoler de faire du sport ou de lire
des bandes dessinées et je n'ai plus
qu'à passer tout ça la fonction du 10
points à ces aides
donc je choisis je prends mon tableau de
données je choisis les variables que je
veux l'inclure dans la cn aujourd'hui ce
qu'on nous intéresse regardé un certain
bac comment en fête rassemble de
pratique d'activités varie en fonction
de l'âge du sexe et niveau d'études et
en ayant une approche descriptive dans
la lys factorielle c'est pas la
récréation qui me proche plus
explicative
je sélectionne les variables pour un
tableau de données qui n'a plus les
mains d'intérêts et je passe l'ensemble
a dû dit assez si j'exécute ceux ci on
va voir le graphique des valeurs propres
je vais revenir sur ce que représente ce
graphique des valeurs propres et ou de
demandes le nombre d'actes que l'on veut
garder dans l'analyse alors s'il ne
recevait pas on peut tout garder là on
n'a pas de preuve de tant qu elles
pullulent
je les sens ça va garder bien au-delà de
ce que de ce que l'on a besoin et vous
voyez on nous dit si on veut reproduire
ce résultat sans avoir l'interaction du
graphique est la question qui nous brûle
le nombre d'actes que l'on regarde et on
peut tout simplement vos copier ses
options la dent du dit assez m
ce qu'elle aime c'est nnf ça veut dire
ne pas faire de graphiques
on ne peut pas nous demander de manière
interactive le nombre d'actes que l'on
veut et nfc le nombre d'avs selon le
nombre d'actes que l'on veut garder et
si on veut garder un nombre tous les
axes qui sont disponibles vous pouvez
remplacer élèves par la valeur 1 1 ça
veut dire infinie et donc du coup ça
permet de garder à cette étape là tous
les éléments tous les axes existants
pourquoi c'est important de désactiver
les parties interactive c'est que là je
suis en train de faire un script je veux
pouvoir faire un scream 2 boutons pour
pouvoir en faire un rapport automatisés
et si j'ai une partie interactive ses
carnets il faut que je donne
manuellement les éléments donc c'est
pour ça de bien distinguer la partie
interactive qui pratique quand on est en
mode exploratoire d'un code 8 plus
facilement reproductible sur le long
cours maintenant qu'on a fait nos tracés
m on peut vouloir faire deux choses la
première le premier élément c'est
éventuellement d'explorer nos résultats
manière interactive
c'est ce que permet le package explore
ça c'est bien pour une première
visualisation des choses mais c'est pas
forcément adapté lorsque l'on veut
c'est pas forcément adaptés aux plus
long cours quand on veut faire un script
reproductible encore une fois on est sur
deux aspects différents
si je veux utiliser explore la commande
c'est donc d'appeler à la fonction
explore du package explore et de lui
passer notre objet là je vais être en
commentaire ici dans le script parce
qu'on essaie quelque chose d'interactif
que je voulais pas garder dans un script
que je pourrai exécutés en une fois par
contre j'ai passé la commande ici et on
va voir le résultat
lorsqu'on exécute explore ça nous ouvre
une fenêtre interactive et la première
chose que l'on présente c'est le tableau
des valeurs propres
alors il s'agit de bien comprendre le
principe des valeurs propres sait que
lille à ce que j'ai passé initialement
le nombre de variables que l'on a passé
une deux trois quatre cinq six sept huit
neuf on avait neuf variable sauf que
certaines variables et des binaires du
dipri non heydarieh morinière des
dépouilles non bah ça peut se
représenter tout simplement avec une
variable 0,1 et puis on avait quelques
variables avec plus de modalités comme
le groupe d'âge ou comme le sexe est en
fait c'est variable là sont représentés
comme dans la régression logistique par
plusieurs sous variable une part ses
modalités
ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que les
variables que l'on deux neveux l'on a
donné fait que l'ensemble de nos
observations étaient représentés dans un
espace à 15 dimensions comme tout à
l'heure à un besoin de ces façades aux
dimensions l'a cette fois ci on était
sur un espace à 15 mentions
c'est pour ça que nous avons un total de
quinze valeurs propres ce qui a fait
l'analyse factorielle c'est de trouver
un nouveau système de représentation
toujours dans un espace à 15,6 mention
donc on
sur 15 axes et se fait l'analyse
factorielle c'est d'abord de trouver un
premier axe qui va maximiser la baril
les variations qui va capter le maximum
de variance cet axe là c'est ce qu'on
appelle le premier axe est là dans le
cas présent nous avons un premier axe
qui arrive à capturer 17% de la variance
et on peut pas faire mieux maintenant on
va regarder dans ce qui résonne
presspass à caractère six mentions donc
sur 14 dimension restantes on va s'y
trouver un deuxième axe qui permet tous
les 2e axe possible on va chercher le
deuxième axe qui va maximiser encore une
fois la variance et là on arrive à
trouver un deuxième axe qui à lui seul
va pouvoir expliquer 11 5% de la
variance c'est à dire des variations
dans l'échantillon autrement dit nos
deux premiers axes arrive à capturer à
eux seuls 28% de la variante c'est à
dire que d'un espace à 15 mentions on
arrive à capturer à peu près un tiers
des variations uniquement sur les deux
premiers axes et ainsi de suite pour
l'ensemble des différents axes et vous
voyez on a dû dernier axe qui explique
plus grand chose est en fait en général
on s'intéresse peu aux derniers dernier
axe ce qui va nous intéresser en
particulier c'est ce qu'on appelle le
plan factoriel et le plan factoriel
c'est celui qui composaient par les deux
premiers axes mais parfois on va aussi
aller regarder un peu plus finement les
axes de 3 ans 4
notamment parce qu'ici les à 203,4
continuer à expliquer pas mal de
variation mais ce qui nous intéresse en
premier lieu ce sont bien les deux
premiers axes parce que les deux
premiers axes arrive à capturer un bon
tiers ici
des variations l'échantillon et dans ses
deux premiers axes peuvent constituer un
bon résumé de ce qui est en train de se
passer
encore une fois le principe de l'analyse
factorielle c'est que si on vous les
croisez toutes nos variable avec toutes
les variables ça fait beaucoup de choses
et on s'en sortent pas et on essaye de
trouver une manière de résumer tout ça
en extrayant ce qui a le plus
d'importance
alors une fois qu'on a un nouveau
système de coordonnées
on peut calculer pour chaque individu
ses coordonnées sur le nouvel sur le
premier acte
le deuxième axe le troisième axe et
ainsi de suite tous les individus
on a un nouveau système de projection et
on peut du coup les représenter dans ces
nouveaux avec ce nouveau système de
coordonnées et avec l'anglais individus
graphique je peux représenter mais
individus sur la ce que je représente
c'est le premier axe est le deuxième axe
par des vous donc là vous avez les
coordonnées des individus sur ce premier
axe à l'horizontale et sur le deuxième
axe en vertical on nous rappelle qu'ici
17% de la variance expliqué pas le
premier axe est que 11% et représenter
son deuxième axe vous avez à gauche des
possibilités de faire varier un certain
nombre de paramètres de la
représentation graphique notamment vous
me dire que vous souhaiteriez voir par
exemple plutôt la représentation du pro
croisième et du quatrième axe vous
pouvez choisir quels sont les axes de
l'année ce facteur d'elle pour vous les
représenter sur votre graphique pour
moment on va essayer de se contenter
uniquement sur le premier et sur le
deuxième axe on a des options ici qui
permet de fait varier la taille des
points si jamais les points
ou trop petits on souhaitait du coup
aller représenter un peu différemment
vous avez ensuite un paramètre qui
permet de faire varier l'opacité des
points donc là en fait les points
ils sont on leur a mis un niveau de
transparence de 50% c'est juste parce
que du coup il ya pas mal d'observation
qui sont situés au même endroit et donc
du coup qui vont se superposer avec un
système de points qui sont transparents
et bien ça va entraîner que là où il ya
peu d'observations peu de poids au même
endroit ça sera clair et puis lorsqu'on
a plusieurs observations même endroit ce
qui est le cas par exemple ici envoyer
c'est plutôt foncée parce qu'en fait on
a plusieurs individus même situation et
donc du coup ils ont représenté au même
endroit et donc c'est une autre manière
de le voir mais vous avez ensuite la
couleur est par exemple on peut décider
de représenter à le faire variablement
en fonction du sexe si je choisis de
faire de représenter faire varier la
couleur de mes points fonction du sexe
donc là du coup on se retrouve avec les
hommes vous présenter en rouge et les
femmes représentées en bluff on se rend
compte que la plupart des hommes sont
situés en bas c'est à dire sur le plan
factoriel etc les femmes sont toujours
présentes et en os et donc du coup il
semble que notre axe 2 quel axe vertical
capture entre autres la distinction
femmes hommes avec les amours présentait
plutôt vers le bas et les fans plutôt
représenté vers le haut par contre le
sexe n'a pas l'air de varier sur le
premier axe je peux représenter ici ce
qu'on appelle les helix vous montre à
quoi ça ressemble un c'est d'essayer
quand on représente un dû
où les points rapport à une variable
on va voir une ne peut calculer une
élite ce qui est un résumé la dispersion
des points et qui permet de voir
justement ainsi les hommes et les femmes
ici se sépare bien est effectivement une
manière un peu plus visuel de voir que
les hommes c'est vers le glas et les
femmes vers le haut mais cas pas
vraiment différence entre la gauche et
la droite
je pourrais aussi représentée ici plutôt
les effets étage hélas quand on répartit
des individus parages si vous regardez a
priori il n'y a pas vraiment de
différence entre le haut et le bas on va
trouver des gens de tous les groupes
d'âge en haut et en bas c'est à dire que
là je participerai que c'est peu a
encore donné sur la kz2 par contre au
vrac les individus âgés sont plutôt
situé sur la droite télé pour orange
qu'à gauche on va trouver les individus
de plus jeunes qui sont les points
rouges il puissiez en garde les les
groupes intermédiaires les 25-45 ans
sont un petit peu plus vers le centre et
on a encore un petit écart après avec le
vert si je mets les helix on voit que
les élites sont décalées les unes par
rapport aux autres et donc du coup ça
suggère plutôt que nous avons un axe 1
qui varient entre autres en fonction de
l'âge et tout l'enjeu quand on va faire
une analyse factorielle ça va être de
commencer à comprendre qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce qui a été capturé par la kz1
et qu'est ce qui aura été capturé par la
kz2 est donc un des gros travaux
quand on fait une analyse factorielle ça
va être deux comme emmener un sens à nos
différents axes alors pour nous aider
plutôt que de représenter un graphique
des individus on peut essayer de
regarder un graphique des variables
alors ils représentés ici c'était pas
tous forcément très facile là en premier
lieu mais l'idée c'est que si je prends
tous les hommes et toutes les femmes
d'accord je peux calculer on va appeler
le pari sans talent et un peu le point
central de ces ellipses qu'on avait tout
à l'heure je vous remontre le graphique
des individus et je vais remettre la
distinction par sexe donc si jamais je
calcule et le barycentre c'est à dire
une sorte de point central pour les
hommes qui seraient un peu le centre
demande ellipses on va situer par là si
je le cherche pour les femmes il va
plutôt se situer par là et c'est
exactement ce que vous avez sur le
graphique des variables c'est à dire
qu'on va avoir un tour de paris centre
des différentes les différentes
variables
ici la variable sexe a présenté en
marron et vous voyez que les femmes sont
situées entre légèrement à droite les
hommes sont ils faits en bareille donc
on retrouve cette idée là que le sexe à
l'air de surtout varié en fonction de
l'acte verticale ou de notre axe 2
si je reviens les groupes d'âge vous
avez le goût des 16-25 est complètement
à gauche
le groupe d'âge 25 45 qui est un petit
pour moi à gauche
les 45 65 se trouve pour le coup un peu
à droite et le groupe d'âge 65 93 lui se
situe complètement ici sur la droite et
donc du coup on voit bien alors là j'ai
pas dire on voit qu'il ya une sorte de
un peu
de gradient quand on prend les paris
sens mais on voit que l'âge varie
essentiellement sur mon axe heures et
puis je vais pouvoir aussi pour notre
activité par exemple la cuisine qui en
date l'heure et bien la cuisine on va
voir que vous avez loïc plutôt la anbari
sentent le nom qui est plutôt leur est
donc la cuisine serait plutôt
s'opposerait plus tôt sur l'axé vertical
on aurait une opposition un peu les
femmes font la cuisine est pas les
hommes et vous arrivez aussi une petite
opposition sur l'axé horizontal et qui
aurait un effet où les jeunes ferait
peut-être un peu plus la cuisine que les
personnes plus âgées est en fait c'est
la proximité entre nos différentes
variables qui va nous permettre de
commencer à essayer d'interpréter tout
ça alors je voulais dit explore c'est un
des outils d'exploration visuel du
graphique et si on sauf que si on veut
récupérer vous passez par le bouton
obtenir le code r pour récupérer un code
reproductible qui permettrait de refaire
le même graphique que celui qu'on a vu à
l'écran
je demande juste une toute petite
seconde
[Musique]
je vous prie de m'excuser pour cette
petite interruption donc explore c'est
un outil qui permette de faire les
choses de manière interactive n'est pas
forcément de reproduire toujours
facilement certains graphique à moins de
recopier certains codes ce qu'on va voir
c'est comment est-ce qu'on peut refaire
tous ces différents types de graphiques
avec les fonctions qui date du 4 mai on
va voir également les fonctions d'un
autre package qui s'appelle facto extra
et le package facteurs extra il fournit
des fonctions graphiques que l'on peut
utiliser avec les objets issus issu
d'une analyse factorielle réalisé avec à
2,4 ou avec une analyse factorielle
réalisé avec facto minder de même
manière un exploit que je vous ai
présenté fonction tout autant avec à des
quatre caves et facto myners alors vous
avez le premier graphique inquiète le
graphique des valeurs propres mais parle
aussi de l'inertie de chacun des axes le
graphique des valeurs propres
il peut se reproduire avec la fonction
ce qui pelote dans la délicate donc si
on fait avec les citadelles 4 on va
faire ce qui pelote et on va lui passer
notre à celles d'autres objets assez m
donc là vous avez le graphique des
valeurs propres
alors ici ce qui a représenté sur l'axé
y
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'inertie bla on
peut interpréter comme la variance
expliqué par chacun des axes et on va
voir que parfois on va essayer de
privilégient plutôt de type de
représentation ou ne va plus pour
représenter les pourcentages
si on veut faire le même graphique de
manière un petit peu plus joli avec
facteurs extra on va dans ces cas-là
utile alors les fonctions de facto
istres de facto extra commence par f
vise pour
factornews visualisation là c'est du
coup la fonction et vise script lot
je lui parce qu'on a c'est m et je vais
dire police égal et dionne value et donc
si je fais cette commande je vais
représenter les valeurs donc c'est les
bébés malheur qu'on avait juste avant
c'est ce qu'on va appeler l'énergie et
donc c'est l'inertie qui expliquait par
chacun des axes sauf que souvent cette
inertie n'altère pas forcément toujours
un sens précis et donc on ce qu'on veut
c'est plutôt exprimé non à l'inertie de
chacun des axes mais le pourcentage
n'est rssi c'est-à-dire l'inertie des ac
/ l'inertie totale c'est à dire le
pourcentage inertie capturé par un axe
est donc dans ce cas là ça se fait avec
elle vise ce qui pelote et en passant
juste assez m
et donc voyez en fait on obtient le même
le mail graphique ce qui change c'est
unique ou en fait l'échelle de notre
présentation ici en vertical et samedi
le pourcentage expliqué donc patienter
jobs explique marianne c'est à dire en
fait l'inertie d'un axe / le total des
inerties ce qui me donne en fait
l'inertie capturé par un pacs et que
l'on peut interpréter comme la variance
expliqué par un axe donné et plus on à
inertie importante sur les deux premiers
axes plus ça serait intéressant parce
que plus on pourra dire que
notre analyse factorielle capture un
grand nombre d'informations alors
l'information l'inertie 1 vous la
retrouvez également quand vous faites un
saut me relis sur l'objet cm
on vous présente ici pour les cinq
premiers axes 1 les valeurs propres ou
ligne acide chacun des axes exprimé en
pourcentage de l'énergie totale et vous
avez ici à la partie inertie cumulé
c'est à dire en additionnant pur et dur
donc on retrouvera les mêmes choses pour
l'inde a vu jusqu'à présent 28 5%
d'inertie qui explique qu'il est
expliqué par les axes 1 et 2
alors pour comprendre la signification
des axes on l'a vu on va essayer de
savoir quels sont les variables qui
contribue à chaque axe pour ça on va
vouloir représenter éventuellement la
projection des différentes variables qui
peut se faire notamment avec ce qu'on
appelait un sexe un cercle des
corrélations et donc pour comprendre
notre notre objet cn si on faire un view
sur l'objet à cm dans quand on fait une
analyse factorielle avec avec à 2,4 on
obtient donc notre jeunesse est un objet
qui contient pas mal d'informations dont
les valeurs propres ici heigl et vous
avez entre autres de de son objet lee
qui correspond aux lignes et qui sont en
fait les coordonnées de chacune de nos
2000 observation selon les différents
axes et vous avez co qui vont être les
coordonnées de nos du centre en fait de
nos nos variable sur les 15 axes et donc
c'est pour ça ici on a 22 lignes 15
colonnes donc quand on va vouloir faire
un graphique sur les lorsque ce qui nous
intéresse c'est un graphique
[Musique]
sur les variables on va souvent passer
aux fonctions de la d24 assez m $ qu
elle un peu quand on voudra faire des
graphiques sur les lignes on passera du
coup assez m $ elle dit donc si je veux
faire mon graphique avec les fonctions
de base daté 24
donc vous avez la fonction est ce que sa
rigueur pour faire un cercle de
corrélation je lis pas ce acl de l'art
seo et vous avez ici
le graphique des corrélations alors
comme si pas bien bien visible on veut
on peut l'améliorer
vous avez un des paramètres alors là on
est plutôt fonctions classiques 1 2
heure vous avez est ce label qui permet
de modifier la taille des étiquettes et
là vous avez un graphique qui va être un
petit peu plus lisible même si certaine
éthique et dont se superposer les unes
aux autres
si j'apprends dit le graphique ce que
vous voyez c'est que là on va retrouver
sexe point sommes donc là on voit où
sont situés les hommes on voit où sont
situés les femmes donc on voit que sur
l'axé vertical
vous avez on va retrouver donc les
amants bas les femmes en eau ce qui va
être très fortement corrélé à l'axone 1
vous avez la pratique de la pêche de la
chasse qui est ici en lui et sur l' axe
horizontal
ça c'est la kz2 par contre en vertical
et sur la kz1 à l'horizontale vous voyez
notamment les groupes d'âge
on a déjà évoqué mais on voit aussi le
niveau d'études primaires qui m'a est
ici professionnel est là et une
secondaire se situe ici et le niveau
d'études supérieur se situe complètement
sur la gauche donc on voit qu'on a un
axe horizontal qui capture pour les
variables sociodémographiques
essentiellement un niveau d'études et
groupes d'âge et il se trouve que le
niveau d'étude ici très corrélé dans
l'échantillon a lâché pour ça que les
deux sont un peu sûr mais ma sur le même
axe à dire qu'on va avoir plutôt des
personnes avec un niveau d'étude faible
sur la droite est âgé et on a plutôt des
individus etc un niveau d'études plus
élevé et un âge plus
mais sur la gauche et puis vous avez sur
l'axé vertical plutôt les amendes à et
les femmes
peut-être que si on voulait distinguer
niveau d'études et groupes d'âge il
faudrait regarder du côté des axes deux
ou trois si on veut représenter avec les
fonctions de facto extra de différentes
variables
on ne peut le faire que ça va être
immense parc des devises vous avez
ensuite mca puisque vous avez une
fonction différente pour la pca pour la
rca ou pour l'analyse knicks donc ici ça
va être mca et ans usage contre inde
pour les individus var pour les
variables
l'hypnose pour faire un graphique mais
cette fois ci je vais prendre les
variables et jules passe nuno cm et
j'obtiens ce graphique une petite
fonctionnalité qui est intéressant c'est
que facteurs extra peut utiliser le
package est géré pen qui fournit une
jolie fille qui s'appelle rappel et qui
permet en fait de mettre des étiquettes
force qu'elle ne se superposent pas donc
si je rentre si je rajoute ici option
lui perd également sa va essayer de
faire en sorte que nos étiquettes ne se
superposent pas et donc du conte à la
fille qui est bien plus lisible
vous voyez donc là ce qu'on a représenté
ce sont de différentes variables
donc c'est toujours les mêmes
prestations tout à l'heure et on
retrouve les embarras les femmes en eau
et du coup ils les différentes variables
comment elles se présentent est ce grave
fille classe si on est vraiment
intéressé et ensuite donc sur ces
graphiques là qu'on va voir ce qui nous
intéresse et août le fait qu'on va
caractériser cette commencèrent pouvoir
lire la manière dont on décrit
finalement les résultats de l'analyse
c'est d'essayer de voir comment les
choses se structure là ce qu'on voit
c'est qu'on a du coup plutôt tout ce qui
va être masculin vers le bas dont la
pratique de la pêche et skis féminin
vers l'europe dont la pratique de la
cuisine on va avoir donc ce niveau entre
gauche droite où on assure la droite
plutôt les niveaux d'étude les personnes
les plus âgées et les niveaux d'étude
est plus faible
à gauche le niveau d'études les plus
élevés et les personnes qui sont plus
jeunes et du coup on voit plus sur ce
côté gauche on à la pratique du sport la
pratique du cinéma et la lecture de
bandes dessinées qui vont être plus
présent on voit que lecture de bd est
aussi un peu plus haut donc on pourrait
se demander s'il n'ya pas un effet aussi
un peu de un peu de sexe
la cuisine se posent sur les verticales
entre cuisine oui et cuisine nom qui est
en bas mais également sur le gauche
droite donc il a probablement à des
associations à la fois sur le sexe et
probablement aussi un effet d'âge et
c'est plutôt les proximités qui vont me
permettre à deux d'interpréter tout ça
alors avant d'aller un petit peu plus
loin
si je
je monte du côté des questions une
première c'est pourquoi les flèches de
certaines modalités des pastels et
limites du sac de corrélation
effectivement sur la représentation
graphique que vous avez ici
en fait ça ne devait pas se servent de
corrélation parce que c'est pas les
c'est pas une corrélation en tant que
tel c'est les coordonnées des points
dans l'espace et c'est juste que c'est
le même graphique que vous avez là c'est
juste que ils ont rajouté une flèche qui
part du sandre et kun a fait un cercle
autour mais la distance au cercle
c'est juste pour rendre les choses plus
visuel mais c'est bien les coordonnées
des modalités d'un plan factoriel qui
sont représentés alors pour faire de
plus beaux graphiques faut-il mieux
coller le code obtenu via explore ou
faire les graphiques avec photo extra
j'ai envie de dire tout dépend du
graphique que vous voulez vous pouvez le
faire avec explore si vous allez en fait
avec facteurs extra vous pouvez
commencer aussi des plein d'options qui
permettent de personnaliser par exemple
de dire je veux remplacer
je voudrais avoir des formes de points
qui vont dépendre de tel ou tel variable
et on peut commencer à faire des choses
encore plus esthétique on peut c'est
juste la présentation un peu différente
si vous vous souvenez du graphique avait
fait explorer la variable était d'une
certaine couleur mais on voyait pas
[Musique]
vous voyez pas en tant que tel les le
titre de la variable sur le graphique là
le nom de la variable ccqs points comme
ça peut être un peu plus explicite
on pourrait aussi avoir une autre
possibilité pour faire un autre
graphique c'est de le faire directement
nous mêmes même à la main alors pour le
faire
[Musique]
si je retourne sur l'exploit d'accord je
vais vous mettre le même graphique avec
export
là ce qui nous intéressait c'était le
graphique des des variables d'accord
vous avez ici on a plusieurs options
pour faire varier part variable ou par
non de modalités
vous avez ici obtenir le code r donc si
je prends en seront tous là je clique
dessus
j'obtiens le code r pour pouvoir refaire
le même graphique avec explore je viens
de le sectionner jeu les copier je
quitte ma représentation et je te coller
ici
donc ça c'est le code complet pour le
refaire la particularité c'est que
toutes les toutes les options sont
indiqués ici dans eve isma mca var vous
avez aussi plein d'options disponibles
et quand vous allez sur fichier dead
vous pouvez vous rendre compte qu'il ya
plein d'éléments qui peuvent être
ajoutées sur les différents types de
graphiques donc on peut commencer à
explorer pour faire ses propres
graphique ce qu'on voit aussi c'est que
explore a commencé à préparer les
résultats d'accor et les emmys un objet
raison alors voyons voir ce que contient
cet objet raison
si je fais un str derez enfin si tu veux
en sorte que la capture des cons se
passe bien j'ai un premier en fait 13
préparer les données dans un certain
format et on voit qu'on a déjà un
premier niveau qui est un tableau vars
qui contient des informations sur les
différentes variables y en a plein après
si on en fait si on veut pousser si je
reviens sont assez m je prends l'object
co qui contient les colonnes ce que vous
avez ici c'est un tableau avec 22
observations 15 variable donc l'idée
c'est qu'on a une observation par par
centre j'ai envie de vous dire le plus
simple en fait c'est prenez le graphique
qui vous convient le mieux
après il ya moyen de bidouiller mais je
vous avoue j'ai pas fais ça depuis je
pense plusieurs années les moyens de
bidouiller pour récupérer les données
dans un format qui permet de faire son
propre graphique ggp lot on peut
vraiment arriver à faire le graphique
qu'on a envie mais j'ai pu enfin je les
plus sous la main et souvent je pense
qu'entre explore et facteurs extra vous
arrivez à faire un graphique qui peut
vous convenir et si vraiment il ya
besoin d'aller plus loin
d'aller plus loin il faut voir si on
peut récupérer les données dans quelque
chose permet de faire quelque chose de
plus esthétique ce qu'il faut retenir
c'est que souvent ce qu'on a envie c'est
parfois aussi de représenter les deux en
même temps
pardon si je reviens sur le explore de
tout à l'heure vous avez aussi ce qu'on
va appeler des graphiques avec et les
individus et les variables
c'est une le graphique 10 ans big block
est donc là où la représentent les deux
éléments il ya vraiment moyen de jouer
un peu sur ce qu'on veut faire et ce
qu'on veut obtenir de manière
interactive pour explore et pour
facteurs extra en fait quand on retourne
sur l'aide de facto extra on va
découvrir d'autres éléments mais vous
avez aussi et vise mca le bipe note si
je veux pas assez m
ce double ce double graphique
alors là il n'est pas très très visible
mais ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que dans
les deux cas vous avez plein d'options
qui sont possibles pour personnaliser le
graphique et en explorant du côté de
facto extra si on est vraiment avoir un
certain graphique très spécifique qui
doit y avoir moyen de récupérer les
données dans un format pour contrôler de
manière fine un ce que voulait
représenter
par contre il peut y avoir des
graphiques supplémentaires que fournit à
des 1/4 et qui peuvent aider aussi à
bien comprendre qu'est ce qui se passe
sur les axes donc c'est plutôt des
graphiques qui vont aider soit en tant
qu'un pas forcément qu'on publie ramé
qui vont servir à un moment donné pour
bien comprendre ce qui se joue et en
particulier je montrais le box bloc
si je fais box plock de assez m voilà
pourquoi mange pas
à ses amis mais là je crois savoir
pourquoi ça ne marche pas il aurait
fallu que je fasse ce qu'il n'est pas
content parce que je suis passé par une
syntaxe
alors on va revenir ici ici je vais
mettre mon tableau pense que ce que je
vais faire je vais d'abord créé mon
tableau je fais un tableau j'appelle t2
avec que les variole qui m'intéresse et
ensuite je vais faire un but dit sm ou
je lui passe des deux parents j'ai fait
des bêtises a sûrement copie coller je
reviens donc je vais prendre tout ça je
vais faire un objet d 2 qui contient que
les variables d'intérêt et ensuite au
lieu de passer par une syntaxe à ladite
laier je vais juste faire à cm et il a
dû 10 à cm2 des deux et maintenant on va
refaire vox pop life box blocks il
s'affiche maintenant à l'écran vous le
zoom est donc là par défaut si je ne
précise rien je suis sur l'ex 1
et alors ce qu'on m'a montré comment les
différentes variables de l'acm se
répartissent sur mon axe sur mon ex 1
je vois bien que les 7 vallées qu'il ya
un effet un surnage en et 65 93 jusqu'au
16 25 et je vois bien que la la j'ai
assez différent sur l'ex l'un avec vers
des valeurs négatives entre la gauche
les jeunes et vers les valeurs positives
les personnes plus âgées
est-ce que vous avez ce sont des boîtes
à moustache avec en plus la moyenne
représenté par un parent ce que vous
avez après pour la variable sexe on voit
que y'a pas différence sur l'axé liens
entre les hommes et les femmes et donc
que la variable 7 ne joue que très peu
sur ce premier axe quand je regarde mon
niveau d'études
je vois que le niveau d'études et bien
distribué sur le premier axe avec le
niveau primaire sur la droite mais
niveau supérieur sur la gauche on voit
que pêche chasse ne contribue que peu
avec ce 1
on voit une différence sur lecture bd
une différence marquée sur la pratique
du sport
une différence un peu moins marquée mais
malgré tout présente même sur le
bricolage qui était bien là une
différence aussi un peu sur les cuisines
et une différence importante sur le
cinéma je peux faire aussi un box pelote
pour la kz2 donc là je dis je un vote
bloc pour la kz2 et donc on a le même
graphique sauf que cette fois ci on voit
comment tout varie par rapport à cet axe
2 je vous refais le zoom
donc là on voit que le groupe d'âge
finalement il ya se répartit de manière
un peu qu'ils tapent sur l'action de y'a
pas trop différence pour le sexe on voit
quand même que là pour le coup les
hommes ont des scores négatifs les
femmes des scores positifs
donc si vous oubliez notre actu dont le
représentant général en vertical c'est à
dire les hommes emballent et femmes
euros
il ya assez peu de différence du niveau
d'études
à l'exception peut-être du niveau
technique professionnel qui se distingue
un peu sur la kz2 qui est plus vers le
bas et c'est peut-être lié au fait que
les personnes qui ont un niveau
technique ou professionnel sont peut
être plus souvent des hommes que des
femmes
on voit que la pêche la chasse là il ya
une claire différence sur l'action donne
par contre la pratique du cinéma varie
peu sur 7
2 sur la cuisine on a un écart peut-être
parce que les hommes seraient ceux qui
font pas cuisine sont un peu plus
souvent des hommes que des femmes
même si c'est pas si marqué que ça mais
faut pas oublier que la variable qu'on a
dans l' enquête c'est pas la pratique de
la cuisine quotidiens mais plutôt de la
pratique la cuisine comme passe-temps
pour le bricolage on voit qu'il ya des
variations important sur cet axe 2 et
probablement à mettre en regard avec les
différences de sexe puisque on voit que
ceux qui font du bricolage sont plutôt
vers le bas donc plutôt court et avec le
fait d'être un homme et qui a par contre
pas de variation de la pratique du sport
boules sur cet axe 2 donc box pelote
ça permet d'analyser que axe par axe
mais est un outil qui peut être
intéressant pour pour bien comprendre ce
qui se joue une autre manière de
regarder les variables qui peuvent jouer
sur certains axes et pas sur d'autres
c'est de passer par là facto extra vous
avez aussi la présentation elle vise
contre yb je lui passais la cm ce qui
m'intéresse c'est de voir la
contribution des variables auchan lycée
galvan et là je vais regarder ce qui se
passe sur l'action donc je vous montre
cette représentation graphique l'un ça
vous montre un peu une contribution des
différentes variables aux axes avec un
niveau de contribution plus ou moins
important et là ce qu'on voit simplement
sur notre action les variables qui
contribuent le plus à cet axe là sont le
niveau d'études primaires le fait
d'aller au cinéma de pratiquer du sport
le groupe d'âge est donc en fait on va
avoir des variables dont une grosse
partie des variations sont sur cet axe
eu un jeu pourrait faire la même
opération sur la kz2 et l'art va voir
le sexe qui contribuent et la pêche la
chasse et demi que la joie on allez vas
y contribuer le plus sur cet axe 2 donc
ça commence à nous aider et ça peut
aussi permettre de regarder ce qui se
passe un peu quand on regarde aussi des
axes 3 et 4 qui dans certaines analyses
on peut avoir besoin
il y aller vous avez aussi
[Musique]
le alors le rapport de corrélation ya
moyen de regarder aussi la corrélation
entre les variables et les axes alors là
on a pu les modalités mais la création
globale des variables est ce assez
contenues dans l'objet à cmcr dollars
c'est m alors je vous avoue le petit
graphique en question le bon souvenir
jamais comment le faire donc c'est pour
ça que je vais faire quand je sais plus
je le fais directement en allant sur le
site analyse r mais vous avez versé ce
graphique la gelée copier le code parce
que je ne m'en souviens jamais je vous
avouerai mais si je vous le mets donc là
on a faim graphique à avec les quatre
accès on voit du coup les variables qui
contribuent le plus aux différents axes
donc on voit que les variables qui sont
le plus corrélés avec ce 1 c'est le
groupe d'âge le niveau d'études
le fait de faire du site de d'aller au
cinéma puis de manière un peu plus
secondaires la pratique du sport et
enfin de manière plus cher le bricolage
la kz2 les barques sont plus corrélés à
la kz2 et bien c'est le sexe la pêche et
la chasse les niveaux de bricolage et
puis on voit que si on allait regarder
de manière plus fine les actions 3,4
qu'on a pas fait jusqu'à présent
cela n va qui vont varier sur le groupe
d'âge et l'apathie de la cuisine de
l'action 4 plutôt sur la lecture de la
bd et le niveau d'études
c'est à dire qu'en fait l'acte iii et iv
permettrait de distinguer les faits dans
le côté niveau études et le côté h qui
sont en fait un peu mêlé sur l'axé ça
allait regarder les actions d'axa peut
être pertinent lorsque
vraiment un sport de manière plus fine
[Musique]
voilà alors petite précision ici ce
qu'on a fait si vous la regardez le code
à l'occasion c'est qu'en fait on
là on est vraiment sûr de la syntaxe
base est l'un des plus hauts du gp2
qu'on a qu'on avait vu jusqu'à présent
c'est pourtant la t4 graphique avec un
parent pilote par pilote
on a fait un bar club de la première
colonne de la cmcr qui ont fait quatre
fois et en fait le paramètre par mf ou
l'audace et de 2,6 pour dire je veux
combiné des graphiques en deux lignes de
colonnes et je vais remettre ce
paramètre à 1 1 pour pas un graffiti
donc là vous avez un mélange de code un
peu à l'ancienne
ce qu'il faut aussi savoir c'est que ade
4 et facto mineurs mein herr ce sont des
package qui sont très anciens qu'on
disait nous amis d'année je crois que le
chapitre analyse factorielle sur analyse
a aussi un des plus anciens et donc vous
avez du cours de cette coexistence entre
des package qui sont sur une syntaxe on
va dire un peu traditionnelle de nos
horaires et puis du coup dé nouveau
package comme explore pour la partie
interactive ou facto extra qui essayent
de représenter sa avec une souche plus
tôt à nager pote plus plus récentes
alors on l'a vu on peut représenter les
individus d'un plan factoriel à je vais
vous faire graphique des individus par
exemple avec elle vise mca inde
mais si je vous présente les individus
akers étiquette a bien un petit peu dur
à lire donc déjà ce qu'on va faire c'est
je vais indiquer géoméga de police pour
dire que je veux que les points et je ne
veux pas en plus les étiquettes parce
que les noms de personnes d'ici font pas
sens et puis on va rajouter un paramètre
alphapro inde égale pro 25,1 pour mettre
un peu de transparence parce que les
points sont tous les uns au-dessus des
autres
alors je me pose une question
oubliez ça donc ce qui se passe qui
effectivement on a les qui se passe il
ya les observations qui sont même
endroit elle raconté on va redémarrer la
session m
alors on part exécuter tout le début
vous avez d'autres types de
représentations voyez en fait il ya des
points qui sont même endroit parce que
vous avez plus d'un individu qui ont
répondu à l'identique et du coup c'est
pas toujours bien visibles où est ce
qu'ils sont une possibilité
[Musique]
c'est alors je vous donne les astuces
mais vous avez il ya un petit package
que je que je fais qui s'appelle gel
utilise alors ce package là c'est un
paquet de trucs et astuces et il est par
défaut que sur youtube
parce que voilà c'est un package qui
l'accueillait fonctions un peu temporel
temporel en fait qu'ils sont un peuple
oratoire des choses de trucs et astuces
ce package vous les trouverez pas sur
crans vous pourrez pas d'installer par
l'onglet package et si vous voulez
installer c'est possible avec des tous
2.2.1 stade dit hublard marange sache jl
tice et du coup si vous l'avez à
il ya danger mitis une fonction qui
s'appelle s points ferait qu est l'idée
c'est que vous lui passait donc à cm2
narli et en fait ça vous fait ce
graphique là et la taille des carrés
correspond au nombre d'observations donc
ça avons refait la même chose qu'on
avait c'est à dire notre notre nuage de
points
on a là là on a juste des points qui
sont transparents et donc du coup ils
devaient plus ou moins foncée suivant
qu'on a des observations
là vous avez une replantation un peu
alternative où on représente le nombre
de personnes observées on avait le point
et vous voyez que ça nous donne une
autre vision du nuage de points parce
qu'on voit qu'il ya des endroits qui
sont bien plus peuplée que d'autres une
possibilité d'utiliser une fonction
daddy yod 4 qui s'appelle est ce point
east est ce point east
je lui passe à ses amis donc les lignes
et donc ça nous représente le nuage de
points
alors sauf qu'on va supprimer les
étiquettes
donc ça se fait ainsi la belle égal 0 et
7 h 15 pour changer le type de graphique
donc voilà j'ai supprimé les étiquettes
à quel nom d'observation dont vous voyez
les observations qu'ils ont représenté
ici un axe un axe n'accepte mais vous
avez juste au dessus et un histogramme
où se situent les individus donc on voit
qu'il ya plus de monde sur la partie
haute du graphique sur la partie basse
donc c'est aussi une manière de voir où
sont situés les individus alors assez
souvent on a intéressé pour voir comment
se répartissent certains individus par
rapport à certaines variables et donc ça
typiquement par exemple si je veux
représenter mon nuage individus en
fonction du sexe je peux faire avec les
fonctions classiques
à 2,4 à la fonction s class je lui passe
les points et puis-je indique donc là ça
va être des deux sexes un facteur qui
m'intéresse et donc du coup là je vais
présenter les hommes et les femmes pour
ce soit peut-être plus facile vais faire
comme je vais passer d'une couleur rise
of wind et la du power le green it est
un peu pétanque à mettre un tacle donc
là j'ai passé de nos couleurs vous
pouvez aussi passer d'évêques des
palettes de couleurs on en a déjà parlé
vous avez un chapitre entier sur les
palettes de couleurs sur l'analyse a
bien sûr on peut faire la même chose
tout simplement avec f vise mca inde
donc les individus je lui passe assez
mgm est gérée megan hunt pour n'afficher
que les points n'est pas fiché les
étiquettes et via moyens de faire un
binage égale des deux marques sexe dont
je lui donne une variable un là vous
avez les points et on a aussi l'option à
d'ellipses exacto donc ça c'est comme
comme on l'a vu précédemment
une des questions qui est posée c'est
peut-on ajouter des variables
supplémentaires une des variables dites
illustrative à la sem avec à 10h04 alors
ça peut tout à fait se faire et de deux
manières différentes
là par exemple je pourrais être
intéressé par une variable et j'aurai
dans mon fichier qui n'auraient
à contribuer au calcul de la cm
j'aimerais voir comment ça serait parti
si je reprends hd les deux points et
donc si je regarde les variables que
j'ai qu'on n'a pas utilisée
on peut avoir la variable religion la
variable religion qui est tu étais une
de novak est une des variables du
fichier mais que je n'ai pas utilisé
dans l'alsace et m je ne pourrais me
demander mes esprits mais individus ils
sont comme à ce qu ils se répartissent
dans le plan factoriel donc je peux
utiliser dans la classe
hdv 2003 d'audard religieux alors je ne
peux me permettre d'aller chercher un
vecteur de hdv 2003 alors que j'ai
calculé la cm sur des deux à ce que à
aucun moment je n'ai changé lors des
observations donc là lors de mes
observations et bien même dans mes
différents tableaux et donc là je fais
du coup à mon graphique selon la
religion où je peux le faire dans mon
église ici donc je vais utiliser
hdv 2003 dollars religieux
et donc du coup là je vais bien
représentée et vous avez d'une part là
les ellipses et puis vous avez des gros
points plus gros centre a cédé paris
centre qui nous ont présentés si je
retire les ellipses pour alléger la
lecture donc là je représente en fait un
pas dans le plan d'une variable il n'a
pas servi calcul de l'analyse
factorielle mais je représente les
individus du coup en fonction de cette
variable là et ça me permet de voir du
coup aussi il ya des différences entre
entre pratique une autre
sa sereine ce qu'on va appeler une
variable illustrative et c'est comme ça
qu'on va récupérer l'information pour la
variable administrative alors ce qu'il
faut comprendre c'est qu'est-ce qu'on
fait entre une variable illustrative une
variable intégrer le principe c'est que
on peut utiliser analyse factorielle
pour différentes les différentes
manières de m'utiliser
par exemple dans des enquêtes auprès des
ménages en afrique subsaharienne pour
estimer les conditions de vie des
individus on va avoir toute une série de
questions qui va être est ce que vous
avez un frigo est ce que vous avez une
cuisine est-ce que vous avez un vélo est
ce que vous avez une voiture
quel est le type de chauffage quand vous
avez le type de sol de type de mur le
type de toise que ça transforme un toit
en tôle droit avoir plein de questions
sur les conditions de vie des ménages
est en fait à partir de ça on voudrait
refaire un indicateur est ce que les
gens sont pauvres ou riches et donc du
coup on parle de toutes ces variables
qui décrivent des conditions de vie du
ménage
on va faire une analyse est prêt
cependant ce multiple on va récupérer
uniquement le score des individus sur le
premier axe est envahie si ce score sur
le premier axe pour un indicateur de
pauvres ou riches s est donc on va
refaire des quintile des individus sur
ce premier round
on peut utiliser l'analyse factorielle
plus tôt pour voir comment les les
les modalités se regroupent les unes par
rapport aux autres ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que l'analyse factorielle va être
très fortement sensibles aux modalités
atypique
si vous avez quelques modalités
représenté par peu d'individus savoir
tendance à capturer une grosse partie
l'analyse factorielle et ils m'ont est
un petit peu à l'écart là on aurait pu
se demander est-ce qu'on n'aurait pas
est-ce qu'on avait pertinence à m dans
l'analyse factorielle
les variables âge sexe et itude
peut-être pas ce qui m'intéresse c'est
d'abord de faire de voir quels sont les
[Musique]
loisirs qui s'articulent les uns avec
les autres pour voir si j'ai des groupes
de loisirs qui émergent et seulement
après je veux croisé ça avec l'âge ou la
religion au sexe pour faire un exemple
d'une action alternative je vais faire
un objet t3 et là je vais mettre que les
pratiques
on va pas mettre le niveau d'études et
je retire les variables
sociodémographiques et donc je vais
faire une deuxième à cm le code de la
scène il est là je vais l'appeler à cm2
je vais partir d'un objet t3 donc là
dans cette nouvelle à cm je n'ai plus
que les variables de loisirs donc ce que
je veux regarder simplement il ya
certains loisirs qui se combinent les
uns avec les autres
je n'aurais ne cherche pas du tout
moment à voir où se situent les hommes
ou les femmes si j'explore mes données
on va faire un exploit de cette deuxième
assez m
donc ce qu'on voit c'est que là on a
moins de variables de départ donc on
arrive a expliqué 25% de la variance sur
premier axe et 42 % quand on prend les
deux premiers axes on voit que les deux
premiers axes capture une plus grande
partie de la variance si je regarde le
graphique des variables pour essayer de
comprendre un peu comment les choses se
pose sur lac ce pain là on a à droite
les gens qui ne font quasiment pas
d'activité bien sûr ceux qui font des
activités donc il semble qu'on a le
premier opposition entre ceux qui font
beaucoup d'activité et ceux qui ne font
pas d'activité et mon axe vertical un
peu l'opposition des chasseurs d'un côté
puis on aa bricolage puis cuisine puis
ça c'est le sport puis en tant cinéma
puis lecture bd
donc on aurait finalement deux
oppositions sur mon axe horizontal un
peu entre eux des gens qui font de
l'activité et les gens qui ne pratiquent
pas d'activité et sur un axe vertical un
peu une opposition entre deux types
d'activité est en fête avec pêche chasse
d'un côté puis bricolage cuisine art
c'est vrai que ça fait ça semble un peu
des activités de personnes plus âgées ou
pour ural et puis l'autre côté lecture
bd cinéma sport qui seraient des
activités d'être plus active au plus de
personnes jeunes à voir si on retrouve
quand on croise avec d'autres variables
donc la voyez on n'a pas du tout la même
type
d'analyser si je regardais les
contributions sur les axes comment les
faits tout à l'heure en prenant cette
fois ci à cm2 je m'intéresse vraiment
deux premiers actes et bien
effectivement j'ai alors là oui
effectivement c'est si toutes les
variables pêche chasse oppose vraiment
sur la kz2 et puis toutes les autres
variables survaleurs donc on a un
premier axe faire de l'activité ne pas
faire d'activité et un deuxième axe qui
va être plutôt sur un gradient sur les
types d'activités maintenant que j'ai
fait mon âne elles m'ont à cm2 je
m'intéresse mais qu'est ce qui se passe
quand je regarde en fonction du sexe
dont classe fois ci nos plans le sexe ne
contribuent pas au calcul du plan
factoriel là on a fait une assez m qui
houleux pour factorielle n'est calculé
que par rapport aux activités
donc j'essaye de résumer la formation
type d'activité et je regarde comment se
positionnent les hommes et les femmes
j'étais très ajouté le à l'ellipse et
glamour hélas ce convoi - je vous
l'avais dit l' axe horizontal était
plutôt un axe gens qui font l'activité
vers ces gens qui font pas d'activité et
là on voit que le sexe ne joue pas trop
l axe vertical était plutôt sur un type
d'activité avec le pêche chasse puis
bricolage vers le bas et puisse au
cinéma vers le haut et on voit pas non
plus vraiment de variation ici
du sexe et donc du court ça voudrait
dire qu'il n'a pas fondamentalement de
si grande différence que ça dans les
profils d'activité entre nos hommes et
nos femmes de notre échantillon et par
rapport aux activités qu'on a pris en
compte par contre si je regarde
maintenant le groupe d'âge
est-ce que là on va avoir des
différences alors si je prends cette
fois ci le groupe d'âge on voit émerger
un sur le côté gauche droite des
variations importantes avec eh ben on
voit bien qu'un effet d'âge sur l'axé
horizontal donc sur le premier axe qui
est plutôt entre faire des activités ou
ne pas faire des activités au global et
bien les personnes âgées sont plutôt sur
la droite du côté où on fait pas ou peu
d'activité et les jeunes sont plutôt sur
la gauche sur le côté où on va faire on
va faire différents types d'activités
alors dans tous les cas ce qu'il faut
retenir c'est que l'analyse factorielle
est toujours un peu compliqué à analyser
ça nécessite de bien connaître le
domaine où on est elle n'est pas si
compliqué que ça à mettre en oeuvre
calcul dont m et aujourd'hui je vous
fais une séance vraiment très courte
on voit surtout comme aux jeux met en
oeuvre à dennis factorielle d'horaires
si vraiment c'est intime d'analystes qui
vous intéresse sachez qu'il ya beaucoup
d ouvrages sur la grille ce facteur et
social on peut l'utiliser de plein de
manières différentes
c'est vraiment un outil qui peut être
alors c'est un outil qui est très
intéressante dans une phase exploratoire
de se donner et on essaie d'y voir un
peu plus clair
parce que parfois la dce factorielle va
commencer à nous donner des hypothèses
qu'on va pouvoir aller vérifier de
manière un peu plus fine
par contre c'est parfois plus difficile
a publié mais tout dépend de qu'est-ce
qu'on veut voit ce qu'il faut retenir
c'est que l'objectif de l'analyse
factorielle c'est pas de rendre compte
de tout c'est d'essayer d'aller voir
quelles sont hantées en fait de
simplifier nos données pour voir quels
sont les éléments principaux qui oriente
les variations dans l'échantillon qu'on
va avoir un dernier élément qui peut
être intéressant c'est la fonction
j'oubliais mais vous avez aussi dans la
délicate vous avez une fonction qui
s'appelle scatter si je lis pas ce jeu
refaire sur la première donc je vais
passer ce capteur ici
et puis je vais pas signer une palette
de couleurs alors je vais les chercher
dans colombe rêve
il avait déjà abordé un moment donné
cr que l'employeur peut alors wever pas
les sabres je vais chercher la fonction
brévannes val de l'eyre que le rêveur
mais je veux juste sortir quelques
couleurs cinq couleurs de la palette
c'est un don de skaters ça permet de
réaliser directement un petit graphique
pour toutes les variables qu'on a inclus
dans l'analyse factorielle pour les
différents sous groupes
donc c'est tout à fait le type de
graphique on avait fait jusqu'à présent
on vous avez les données d'observation
et essayez aussi un autre outil qui
permet assez rapidement de bien de bien
repérer comment interpréter nos
différents axes puisqu'on voit la
contribution on voit bien comment se
répartissent les gens sur chacun des
différents axes et je vous leur fais ici
avec à cm2 un pareil on voit bien que à
part pêche chasse qui s'opposent sur
l'axé vraiment sur cet axe vertical dans
les autres variables sont beaucoup sur
le premier axe avec les wheat d'un côté
les noeuds pour aller plus loin pour
aller plus loin vous retrouverez aussi
dans chapitre analyse r comment réaliser
l'analyse la cm avec facto myners donc
avec c'est juste que du coup on va avoir
recours à la fonction mca vous sachez
que les fonctions l2 explore et de
facteurs extra fonctionne également avec
avec facto myners vous avez aussi
facto chimiques et une extension qui a
été développé par une même personne de
facto mein herr qui propose d'explorer
les résultats de manière interactive
dans une philosophie un petit peu
différente d'exploit de explore et sans
avoir non plus le moyen de copier coller
du code pour reproduire les mêmes
graphique il puis vous avez aussi des
rapports un peu automatisé de facto
investi gates vous en trouverez plus
d'exemples ici mais en fait c'est on lui
passe une analyse factorielle il va
automatiquement en fait générer un
rapport un peu automatique des
différents graphiques des différents
axes avec des aimants description si
quand on veut vraiment automatiser les
choses ça peut être pour certains ça
peut être intéressant pour d'autres pour
d'autres pas forcément je regarde s'il
ya des dernières questions à la session
d'aujourd'hui
donc je vois ici une question de tête
rigal et faut-il prenant compte les
pondérations les plan d'échantillonnage
les enquêtes
c'est une très bonne question sur le
point d'échantillonnage les enquêtes
à ma connaissance il n'y a pas d'outils
qui permettent de prendre en compte un
plan d'échantillonnage enquête dans
l'analyse factorielle mais je ne suis
pas forcément sûr que ce soit nécessaire
ce qui joue en fait dans l'analyse
factorielle là pour être dans des jeux
un peu plus technique sait c'est que les
individus alors je crois à faire revenir
sur tout le
les outils mathématiques ya derrière je
suis pas forcément toujours très bon là
dessus mais ce qui va compter c'est les
répartitions
alors je crois pour l'analyse des
correspondances multiples en tout cas
c'est ce qu'on appelle à 10 ans du fils
de c'est à dire qu'à un moment donné
dans votre espace factorielle des
modalités qui sont rares en avoir plus
d'impact des modalités qui sont
fréquentes donc le fric en marginal de
certaines modalités vont avoir un impact
dans l'analyse factorielle et donc il me
semble mais je vais te jure ne pas dire
des bêtises je suis pas un spécialiste à
nice factorielle que du coup c'est
important de prendre en compte les cons
des rations par contre sur les plan
d'échantillonnage ce n'est pas forcément
nécessaire
si vous avez des données pondérées
il semble effectivement que dans
l'analyse factorielle c'est préférable
de les prendre en compte
et lorsque vous faites une analyse
factorielle avec dudit assez m
si vous regardez l'aide de la fonction
du 10 acn vous pouvez passer des points
et c'est avec du coup le paramètre ou au
point w donc là en fait c'est ce que je
veux nous dit la valeur par défaut un
séquel par défaut ça vaut un pour tous
les individus tout simplement mais vous
pouvez avoir un vecteur de points que
vous passez donc il n'est pas dans le
tableau de données vous mettriez pas
dans des deux vous mais vous passez le
vecteur a pas donc comme précédemment à
ce que vous feriez ça serait si je viens
ici ça ce serait de dire des 2 simon
sous-ensembles gérer 2003 et jeffrey
owens point w égale hdmi 2003 dollar
poids puisque ce qu'on passe ici c'est
que les variables de la crm et
à la suite alors il ya une autre
question qui était est il possible
d'aller plus loin d'obtenir les
coordonnées des modalités illustrative
pour chacun des axes alors avec la ds4
je ne sais pas trop je crois qu'il ya
une astuce mais je me range m'en
souviens pas qui permettrait
[Musique]
vraiment je crois qu'il ya une astuce
qui permet en fait des axes additionnel
ils pouvaient demander à au projet dans
l'analyse factorielle
est ce qu'il n'ya pas a prédit que
quelque part dans 2 4 g + l'astuce là
mais je crois que c'est possible pour
les variables illustrative avant que ça
se passe dans la page il doit y avoir
une solution c'est juste que je les
puceaux moment il faudrait faire un peu
de recherche internet pour facto myners
donc si je charge facto mein herr donc
pour facto myners donc on l'a vu à la
fonction de facto manière c'est la
fonction mca et si je regarde l'aide de
mca
[Musique]
si on regarde l'aide de mca vous avez
en fait vous indiquez votre objet x avec
un terme donné avec les individus et les
colonnes que l'on veut avoir
mais en fait on peut directement en lui
passer les individus supplémentaires des
variables quantitatif supplémentaires et
des variables qualitative supplémentaire
à cette étape là et donc du coup là
attendent excusez moi en fait on lui
passe le tableau entier et ensuite on
indique victorine décline verdict 6,9 de
pente ita team supplémentaires jim
albaugh
par exemple nous avons passé un tableau
où il a dit variable et vous diriez
accueilli su me terrier égale 8 2.9 pour
indiquer que la 8e et la 9e colonnes
doivent être traités comme des pommes
une valeur qualitative supplémentaires
si je reprends du coup mon exemple ici
variable supplémentaire avec
donc là je vais charger facto mein herr
donc on va faire assez m3 donc là je
fais mc 1
je vais pas citer deux alors je vous
rappelle un des deux
juste pour
je vous fais une lime ce fut tout
simplement des deux ans on s'était
groupe âge sexe est une richesse lima
dont c'était ce groupe là donc on avait
neuf colonnes pour 2000 variables que je
vais faire mca de t2
je vais indiquer que kelly super cd
variable 1 à 3 donc si je ne me trompe
pas on va vérifier ça donc là on a fait
la cm avec avec du coup facto my name
mais voyez sexe études et groupes d'âge
là sont indiquées dans le plan de
projection mais mais ne sont pas
utilisées pour les calculs de laisser m
donc là elles sont directement et on va
pouvoir récupérer les différentes
informations
si on a besoin juste pour faire
l'exemple si on fait explore de du coût
de cette troisième assez m
on va voir aussi quelques probablement
quelques
[Musique]
donc là où
vous voyez là on a toutes les variables
sont présentés ici on nous indiquer les
variés d'activer supplémentaires par un
symbole
donc le nid on voit bien qu'au niveau
d'étude primaire secondaire supérieur et
du coup il est en variable
supplémentaire puisqu'il est pandaria
victime et on voit bien à on retrouve le
pêche chasse de tout à l'heure il ya je
crois juste un effet à l'inversé si vous
souvenez tout à l'heure on avait je
crois ce qui pratiquait la pêche la
chasse étaient toutes en bar et ceux qui
ne pratiquent pas été tout en haut et
puis ce qui le fait de faire des
activités plutôt à gauche avait fait
naître pour avoir été à droite
non on voit qu'il ya une aversion juste
de signes 1 - plus des deux côtés si je
ressors l'envoyer que le graphique aussi
des représentations de variables suite
qui nous un qui nous est présenté ce
graphique facto myners indy en fait
quels sont les variables qui contribue à
chacun des axes et là c'est plutôt du
coup sûr des questions de corrélation et
on voit bien que pêche chasse il est
très fortement corrélé avec ce vertical
mais peu à la kz1 alors que ce sport il
ya l'action encore une fois je suis
probablement pas non plus au courant de
toutes les nouveautés qu'il ya eu sur
sur facto mind et
parce que encore une fois je lui dis moi
j'avais rédigé les chapitres analysé ya
presque une dizaine d'années et je
pratique
l'analyse factorielle que de manière
occasionnelle et donc du coup voilà je
suis peut-être pas tout à fait à jour
donc c'est pour ça
sachez en tout cas quels sont les deux
points d'entrée à 2,4 et fac thomas
hiver sachez qu'on trouve beaucoup de
littérature sur sûr c'est sûr c'est sûr
c'est sur ces package sur internet et
donc voilà faut pas hésiter à explorer
et si vous avez d'autres questions vous
hésitez pas j'essaierai de compléter
dans les commentaires au fur et à mesure
on se retrouvait semaine prochaine pour
aborder
cette fois ci la classification
ascendante hiérarchie classé hqe yvette
qui en fait est dans la continuité de
l'analyse factorielle ce qu'on va
essayer de faire cette fois ci des
diviser notre échantillon en plusieurs
sous groupes donc comment est ce qu'on
va essayer de faire une typologie
automatique
ça nous amènera du coup à la fin que je
sais aussi que là ce qui fait que dans
deux semaines aux fran une prochaine
séance deux fois aux questions avant de
pouvoir redémarrer sur un nouveau cycle
et là on pourra aborder des domaines où
je suis un peu plus à l'aise autour de
l'analyse de survie d approche
biographique et nos types de d'éléments
plus avancés en tout cas très bonne
soirée à toutes et à tous
à la semaine prochaine et encore merci à
vous au revoir